- Dolly Parton showed interest
and I love her, we just
had her on the show
and she showed interest in
working with you and Cardi B,
which I think,
I think that trio
- Right.
- would be insanely fun.
- You're right.
- Would you ever
do something?
- Absolutely.
Well, I mean, she and
I have been friends for
longer than you've been alive and,
but I would, I would, I always
wanted to work with her.
But you know what, people
weren't doing this as much
back in the day, you know, like,
you know, people would go
on every once in a while,
but it wasn't a thing, you know
it wasn't something that people just went,
oh that would be cool, let's do it.
But, so no
- I do like how music is like that.
It's a little more progressive
now in the sense of like
'cause my whole fear, like I wanted to be
a background singer not a lead singer,
because I wanted to be able to perform
all these different types of
music that I fell in love with
as a kid and made me the singer I am.
And I think that that's
what's cool about you,
you don't stick to one
thing like you never have.
And that's what's so
attractive and captivating
for me about you musically.
But I don't really
think that you and Dolly
are so outrageous, like
y'all coming together,
I think those are just
two icons that are just
so incredibly impressive
musically and as a person,
but also you're just like badass musicians
and like artists and like
so I think that would be really cool.
I'm just saying.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience applauding)
- But then you should throw
in, you should throw in Cardi B
and rap in the middle of it.
- Right, yeah.
- That would be awesome.